it wasn't until two hours or so into my
seven hours of Dead Island 2 when I
finally understood that the linear
nature of the game wasn't just part of
the tutorial and that damn Buster
Studios game wasn't going to eventually
swing its proverbial doors open and
reveal to me the sandbox I was looking
for Action RPGs especially
zombie-centric ones have so often
utilized an open world setting over the
past 15 years that it was for a good
wild jarring to see that Dead Island 2
isn't actually the latest in a long line
of them that took some mental remapping
of what the game is going to be and
while I do find the smaller scope
disappointing it's not without its
benefits too before we really get
rolling I just want to point out that we
weren't able to capture our own footage
that means that all the footage you're
seeing was supplied To Us by the
publisher in my Hands-On time with the
game I visited several areas including
the disgustingly wealthy Bel Air a
dilapidated but probably once five-star
hotel and a formerly proud movie studio
sometimes the way these areas would
snake around surrounded by unclimbable
walls felt very restrictive closer to a
game as tightly set as Bioshock rather
than the original Dead Island's large
hubs where Dead Island 2 ditches its
linear paths is in the many optional
nooks in each area I encountered many
locked rooms safes and loot caches that
would each require further investigation
or even backtracking some of which
wasn't possible in my limited demo these
side attractions be they puzzles or just
temporarily inaccessible gave me the
sense that though the world was narrower
it was also sometimes deeper a great
example came about an hour into the game
when I trekked down the Hollywood Hills
and found myself in a luxurious home
studio belonging to a Media Group of
online influencers and rich kids with a
podcast I had to pass through this as
part of the main campaign but I could do
just that find the key and move along
instead I explored the space and found a
lot more environmental storytelling that
fell deeper than anything in the
original game and perhaps perhaps deeper
than this game could have had if it
hadn't ditched the sandbox
[Music]
the glass panel to make Mansion done up
with a spiral staircase a bowling alley
and a basement bar LED out to an
elaborate sun and blood-soaked poolside
turntable and home gym sports cars
littered the sizable parking area and a
recording room told me about the
streamers who once solicited subs and
donations there it would have been a
lavish place if not for the fact that
the former denizens were now eating
flesh my favorite detail however was a
whiteboard that contained a scripted
apology that a resident influencer was
tasked with delivering to their fans in
the early days following the zombie
outbreak the text of the apology implied
that the influencer was downplaying the
outbreak to their fans truthing it like
we so often see in the real world when
irresponsible people with microphones
convince others to believe bad ideas the
apology script even included prompts of
when to cry and told the influencer to
feign sincerity it was as cynical of of
American culture as Grand Theft Auto has
been for decades and enriched the world
with character and history I didn't
anticipate the original Dead Island was
a much wider world but Dead Island 2
feels Fuller tucking away more stories
in its limited space a boss battle with
a hulking Undead bride left roaming a
reception on the day of the outbreak was
another highlight as the bout did two
things effectively introduced one of the
game's mini boss zombie classes which
would thereafter appear commonly and had
me dancing with the bride to the tune of
Marvin Gaye and Tammy Terrell's sad
wedding a banger in any context but here
it became emblematic of the dark humor
that colors the whole world of Dead
Island 2.
[Music]
environmental storytelling is what might
save the game from criticism regarding
its shrunken world but it's clear
dambuster wants the focal point of the
game to be its combat anyway bashing
zombies skulls and slashing off their
legs isn't a novel mechanic in video
games but Dead Island 2 does it better
than many others and cleverly adds
layers literally to this process weapons
come in different varieties including
maiming headhunting and frenzy these
denote how they feel to use and what
they'll do to the undead
no
head hunting weapons provide a blunt
force maiming weapons are great for
groups of zombies or taking off their
limbs and frenzy weapons allow for fast
slashing and dashing a good zombie
killer will carry several of each in
their weapon wheel and swap them out
regularly for hordes of different sizes
and shapes as you attack the monsters
their bodies will deconstruct with great
detail bludgeon them in the face and
their jaw may hang off like a loose door
hinge or their skin will peel away to
reveal red flesh bones and eventually
brains you can take off their arms to
save yourself from being grabbed each
cut in whack leaves marks making each
zombie kill feel up close and grotesque
in the game's first person perspective
while I expect the game will eventually
move into being a power fantasy I was
glad to see that taking on even just two
or three zombies at a time prove
challenging which meant I had to
strategize how to bob weave hack and
slash with each group of zombies in
order to stay on my feet it's not just
melee combat the game wants to empower
you with but a variety of environmental
kills too from sparking a gas leak with
a homemade electrified weapon you can
craft it a workbench to kicking them
into a pool full of military-grade
poison sludge that causes their skin to
melt off like ice cream in the Sun the
game begs for your creativity so much so
that it can feel too heavy-handed at
times coming upon a horde of zombies not
yet aware of me and standing next to a
bunch of red barrels doesn't make me
feel crafty it feels like I'm pushing a
big glowing action button placed in
front of me other encounters are less
telegraphed however and do a better job
of giving me the tools for Destruction
without the unnecessary instructions
combining my modded weapons throwables
like bait and pipe bombs and things
lying around such as gas canisters or
would-be electrical hazards helps keep
the combat interesting and it's all made
better by being tougher than I expected
good
Co-op wasn't available in My Demo but
the game's three player option means a
full team can load out with half of the
game's cast each of the six characters
has their own personality voice lines
and starting stats though you can't swap
one out for another on the same save
file I made time for an additional
character to see how differently they
play characters have their own special
abilities and though many of the
unlockable skill cards are Universal
some are specific to certain characters
which should mean that character and
team builds are worth consideration one
thing that was the same across both my
characters Amy and Danny was that they
suffered from the video game Trope of a
lonesome hero talking to themselves way
too much but I suspect in Co-op those
lines will be drowned out by real life
chatter anyway Evac centered this way
Halpern Hotel get my sweet ready in all
my time with Dead Island 2 could be
neatly divided in three the first
portion in which I awaited the linear
intro to give way to the sandbox the
longer period once I realized it wasn't
coming and the time between where I had
to to actively recalibrate my
expectations an open world setting does
not inherently make a game better but I
and like many others were reasonably
expecting to find one here hopefully
watching this affords you the ability to
recalibrate ahead of time because I do
think that if you can approach it on
your own terms not those assumed by the
makeup of the first game or implied by
past collaborators on its long road to
release there's reason to believe that
Dead Island 2 has managed to escape
development hell
[Music]
foreign